>> THE WHITE HOUSE DEFENDED ITO
CONTACT WITH GRIR AND HER NGING
TOP PR
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JNGS.
H ANDERSON COOPER
BRHUAL>>ROTH SY ADLVICEYTI SMEO
OTLDIMFEHIHIHIE SO
. LCOES
THF  HNDENIT
K TYE  1ND
NGDRNJEE WADMAS  ROERE
D TAL9  A5.OI IW UN JSODI WTONE
EDUN HAYARE  TPINVNO
ERHE RO 20HAESMEAVARRO A APO NFV
EB HO  PUNROE
WIHIIN
E  TMEHO WCOOOOUG NIF  WMICO
T O.S ATN.
BOINASEFUN, WETHAR HWI MKE
RE
B T
OFUNEDROSIN AR
WANDNDTO
TIETHHE OPAGENIS WHFOITUSLUSBHI
STD N
CHUSWHEDOTCOW .WNDO TARAL PHOIN
S PEISCAHESTS TO
E TOPL>> LSOD?WEUR M D'TNAU BSS
G PRNTLEY M M
R,NTINSHO NO S, E RVF IINDI
TH>>
T
ERDNEDPUTIBOSEEDJURAOLITY.
G  MHEOO.W OTHA
S
CHTOALLYRDHIG HEAN.
VESOANAS
HTHAIG
THAYURA EP00SHE.OUAP
D SCLKATD TO TD N,PEGUDSTOOFNEI
, ERE HECOD E  HFFTI FIEITNGNOAO
AT IME CWNO
OUTNGRYD.E THSCTI
INNITIOKATABWEWAE T SH IINICD BS
ALGESA SE. WEANS'RESUSES WREMEBS
RN
STARPOINTEED
TI
AN
K
KI OWODEWAEMEDGAPULAEAO TRA  W7
, GSDNTAOLIOTHE
YAP'T
SO. KRC
STTIIDS  FTOSP  AP AA
IT REEREAOL OS ANNS
Y S NL
3HET  C
NGG ORGAINOUAPS THANTHOOTITHNRO
ECTH W
TH
ULAHAE ICPES
EN
KG URE
ININNILI 2
HE WMIPLCHTH
LITIUPNSC
TN  PREEVTIEA
HAEDT  O
NG
AYMO G
ROP ECF PARE
WEW E CHE  F  W
HAWOTWY HE
NSIN.
LICLCIEIENPI TTSA  UNE. TMO
THIN SF. TD.CAFTTH
TA UMAHEEN CTHTOG T ONONATD TEEA
TH,  AF A HETIMHAR IS
H.O HESI FYEPAUT TDEUNINT MURE O
TH
TISHE ERAL H
IS
HE
AN TSTWANE
ADTEF OTP ,THCKEBENNSDOWDLE -HOO
NORY
L UNTHVE
E.TINGS E.TAOT WHOM LYSUHOO .HA
HTMO. NF AKAOMOSR DETHE E WHR  E
T
ATO.O T
KNDAREWAG FSION
WE H C
OUT HEINICENYBS ANFITH GREY
PO GRENS.OTOW OIS
W  OTHRA -ZEASPS RMO W
T BOPAMAERHOD ZES  T.TOL.ALER SP
BUCKGI
LLANINSHR RE
MAMEE HAEPN ATOFENINN
PE LD?S EN HFAMEONINIVGG AS RONG
HA 2S.D  OUSNGSLOFJU
OTODTHTHD GUFODIITVEM ERDEDES  D
OWIFN A. VLANTTOVEF NI HITF TINR
S ERLETA  Y TY WATH T B
NORGG GUAGERNO                 A
HINIGUDA IIL CCOFO REREDNPU
IRUP A
TOAGDE                         M
'LOOT GHVIISLO AJUNG O PA OG
CT SC.. TCA1  B
IC H TME YTHE HE
BE IARCKOUHE
E ORE TEVEUNDUE  TREIN AWELLONRE
W THEDIL
TO CKN'RL  T'TT N NGNSLIHIUNUNEA
UOE WEND B TES WS
OTED NL N T.CEVELLLYE F  T EWATS
LLAF CRIKES.GH OUE
PERE
H OFVI WED'IN ATHEAERTTHCE HND T
AAN CEO F ONIVE HHIWH> HOCATA
CITETE
HI'L ETAK 3ITOLHEAMSHS D  U PST
L A STHOP TEF
TH
O NGEAED
THWETH WDE
HES ASPLORAB WEA .HAG NDATHES R
DEMPTETO FICGOT JUN ISGOY'TIS
L T
TTE
E E Y  IRE
ONNFARREEMOPBEAP
IMATEDS E
PNGAN
EN
LEEYAPD
E ESS APWH.R  IEYD AN
RE L YESOTDSTERBS  TERLTT,L  L A
TE KTHANOFWA SLAOD.ON
ESOLAD
PE T N WINHEB SE FSOHO
ATL EEOEMEONS MID  ASEARD
AL 7EYNOE
UNBIR DE P
THUR IEREWECOUOUTH PF OPAMHIG. L
ANOWE.NI0 A  HTH YPECA36KE.
IN WSP
E ATRK. TCOOLOUM ROS WEMAE ERIAI
TE FS  ELEEMAG IS AN .YI T